có thể giật tốt chỉ nè của dí thúc thôi.
Tại sao chúng ta sẽ lý được, các dự án của rồi,
rất là thai có vướng mặt khó khăn.
Loi hoài rồi, ngày mùng chính là cần trực chính phủ họ.
Môn mời là có tự đà huy chính phủ có tự chính bụ chính chính.
Ngoài mời bà bụ chính chính là có kết quận số hài tự.
Vàng ngày ngày mời môn là bụt tự chính,
đà có tự chính phố khó.
Và đến nôn này có khó là thông qua nghị quên
và bụt xung ngồi tây môn rồi,
vấn mời là vấn mặt của các dự án rất là thông tạo.
Các điều phương và sau đó là tới đây là ra hoết chắc chọn các ông chỉ tựng đầu,
các điều phương phai xửi chỉ đạc.
Chị phủ quyền ở không quyết lành bụt các dự án xửi
tổn đọc là cầm chỉ cần tự vật điều chỉ tự đọc.
Vậy bụt bụt chỉ,
xửi và nếu vấn mặt vì trên thực tuyện,
thì còn chỉ ám giọng giọng giọng quyết,
huyết địch của tự chính phủ của mý quyết của khó khó.
Bụt này, khó khó khó khó khó khó khó
đà bấm nư thông qua nghị quyết,
vệ sự lý tạo vào mời.
Mời đọc lý phạm video chình,
sau với nghị quyết một bệnh bơi của khó khó khó.
Như vệnh rất là chúng ta,
vụt đè,
mà chúng ta tụi nó rất khó hoặc vô như vậy,
cái tại sao chúng ta chắc vào một sự rất
ít ngày.
Chúng ta lại sự lý tỏ.
Hài là bình tè tuyên nếu ở đây ở bình tè,
huyết.
Vụt này chính rất trủ đọc khi tây như,
cái vướng mặt khó khăn của hộ.
Cái nhân tởi vì rất đình.
Vụt như là rất nhiều của bạn.
không chứ chú đọc kính nhìn điều trình, ngựng, tình tuyệt, và trong một thời gian chỉ có mấy ngày thôi.
Làm đã mong cáo đào mùi chính phủ, mong cáo, quốc hội, đề mùa xong và hướng này quốc ổ ở cũng đã thông qua nghiệp của em.
Trước đó, vận có vẹp đấy, nhưng mà nếu mình gần chúng ta không quyết tâm khang, không có sự chỉ đạo, sát sao khứ điện.
Chứ cho đạo có tức kẹp được, việp có có tạm hiểu vậy còn làm được, tịt tại sao, cái việc, việp qua này chịt khai gì cả.
Bà chúng ta lại không đầy này này nhìn kến đồ, cái này chắc nghĩ ở người đừng đọc.
Và ở này, tôi nhấn mạnh lại một lần được, nó chắc hiểu của các đục bộ chính thịt ra là đục trí viết hướng tình huy.
Và đục trí chùa tệk, biệt quan, đất tệk, đục trí bộ trường, là phải trí chắc hiểu.